foreign
[Music]
the top stories live from the sky new
city Studio
oil prices surges Saudi Arabia and other
major producers and answer shock
production cut
CEO of the software company one disco
resigns after an internal investigation
identifies more than 115 million dollars
worth of missing bookings
millions of households see their
Broadband bills rise but not all
companies are going for mid-contract
Price hikes
plus could gibraltar's gridlock be at an
end as its new Runway tunnel finally
opens after 14 years
[Music]
foreign this is Ian King live in our
business and economic news from the
heart of the city now the oil prices
shot up by as much as nine percent this
morning after Saudi Arabia and other
members of the OPEC plus grouping
yesterday announced unexpected
production Cuts totaling more than a
million barrels per day well a barrel of
Brent crude which on Friday night was
changing hands at
79.27 per barrel shot up at one point
this morning to
86.44 well the Saudis are going to cut
production by half a million barrels per
day while Russia which is not an OPEC
member but a part of the OPEC plus
grouping said it will extend its
existing half a million barrels per day
production Cuts until the end of the
year Well Brent crude is currently
changing hands at 84.31 cents a barrel
that's up five and a half percent so far
this morning joining me now is Victor
Katona he's lead crude Analyst at Kepler
Victor morning to you I mean this is of
course on top we should remind people of
a two million dollar Barrel per day
production but that was announced in
October
absolutely uh OPEC is doing everything
OPEC plus I should say he's doing
everything that he can to control a
price floor which is palatable which is
to the enjoyment of all of all the
members and effectively it's putting
through a very strong political message
and that's that message is really
manifold first of all OPEC is over plus
is really dissatisfied with how things
have been going with uh effectively a
string of macroeconomic woes destroying
oil prices for them because Brent at 70
is not palatable even though supply and
demand balances are pretty much the same
as they used to be also OPEC plus is
saying no back then the notebook bill in
the United States is not palatable they
are saying it loud and clear we will
react and and I would even say that uh
there's a there's a little sort of as an
undergirding story OPEC plus is also
saying that the fact that the US is not
buying back the sbrs the way that it
promised to be is also not palatable so
it's a very strong political message
it's it's a very uh poignant from from
the Saudi Arabians that they are doing
this effectively three days after
they've they've said that they will be
joining the Shanghai cooperation uh
organization so there's there's a
there's a pivoting in in the oil markets
towards Asia towards more alignment with
with the Asian interest than than with
any other interest in the Atlantic Basin
for that matter yes you touched on the
Strategic Reverb uh reserve the Biden
Administration said only last week it
wouldn't be topping that up after
drawing down quite heavily that seems to
have annoyed the Saudis but why is the
Biden Administration taking that
approach
I think the Biden Administration just
doesn't really want to anger a lot of
its stakeholders it doesn't want to be
seen as as an Administration that's
pro-oil or in any way conducive to oil
prices uh being high so ultimately it
will wait uh it will wait when taking
action will be sort of politically
palatable right now it's not even though
technically technically everything was
about to be uh the SBR replenishment we
had WTI even lower than the 67 to 72
dollar per barrel bandwidth that
initially was put out by the White House
as as you know as the interval when oil
prices dropped to that level we'll start
buying they didn't do it in fact when
oil prices or WTI prices were 65 the
Energy Secretary of the United States
went out saying that we'll be postponing
some of the uh repurchases into into
next year 2024. so again it has become
kind of a nuisance for for the bite
Administration oil as such and because
they perceive it to be that difficult
politically they just don't do anything
they delay decision until until you know
next term next Administration
whatever that might be now you you
raised a very interesting point just now
Victor as well when you said there was
an Asian Dimension to that now Beijing
of course has just broken a diplomatic
deal between Saudi Arabia and Iran is it
possible that China is behind this this
decision or it's had some influence on
it some bearing
well I think that the Chinese would not
like overall higher oil prices however
the Chinese have one thing which most
countries for instance in the Western
World don't really have and that is
security of Supply literally last week
so again what a time to be alive just so
many things happening at the same time
literally last week Saudi Arabia or
Saudi aramco to be specific bought a a
minority stake in China's largest
private refiner not only that it has
also assigned a an exclusive Supply
agreement with another refiner so
effectively the Chinese have contracted
Saudi barrels to such an extent that
they are the largest market for for
Saudis so even though prices are high
the Chinese will always know that
there's a crew that there's crude for
them now with more than one million
barrels per day off of the market
starting from may
not everyone is so so secure not
everyone is so sure that they will get
the the crew that they want and even
more specifically not everyone is so
sure that they will get the crude of the
quality that they want because it might
end up that you have a lot of light
Suites but specifically the medium sours
that the Middle East has always been
specializing in those will be very
scarce and and you know again that's a
privilege that's a that's a benefit to
the Chinese they can always rely on the
Saudis uh to to supply their barrels
everyone else will just have to rely on
the spot Market which is tough
absolutely now Victor what are the
chances do you think of these production
Cuts holding because in the past where
we've seen production Cuts announced the
price goes up and then some producers
attempted by the higher prices to uh to
carry on pumping at the normal rate I
mean Russia in particular is notorious
for that will will this production cut
hold
I think it will hold but there will be
some point of or some moment of
disappointment when a lot of people will
realize that the half a billion
production cup that Saudi Arabia has
pledged has in a way already been taken
place over the past couple of months in
a sense that Saudi Arabia has been
underperforming its quota in January
March 2023 so they will not outright the
half a million they will be just
producing less than they should and the
real production cup would be somewhere
between two and three hundred thousand
barrels so that's the only thing that
that that's going to hit the the market
at some point but overall seeing how uh
willing OPEC plus is in in in in having
that price floor and have an at least
eighty dollars per barrel for Brent if
not more I think that the production cut
story will stay throughout 2023. the
only real story uh concerning the
production Cuts will be will Saudi
Arabia genuinely cut half a million or
will it be less I think it will be less
but in terms of maintain getting a
political message that we're serious
about the price floors we're serious
about what's going on with supply and
demand balances and and the overall
Dynamics and we will take action
whenever that's that's required that
will not change that's the new OPEC plus
mentality and the new OPEC plus
narrative that they're that they're
pushing out
all right Victor we've got to leave it
there appreciate you joining me today
thank you thank you thanks for having me
a bit of breaking news to uh bring you
we've got a bit of reaction from the
government to uh the announcement uh
news that we broke about half an hour
ago on the channel that uh the teachers
union has voted for further strike
action the education secretary Jillian
Keegan has said that after costing
children almost a week of time in the
classroom and with exams fast
approaching it is extremely
disappointing that the National
Education Union have called more strike
action following a week negotiating in
good faith the government offered
teachers a 1 000 pound payment on top of
this year's pay rise a commitment to
significantly cut workload under
headline pay increase of four and a half
percent for next year above both
inflation and average earnings growth
the neu's decision to reject it will
simply result in more disruption for
children and less money for teachers
today
more and that's around the morning here
on Sky News but now some other business
news stories for you and the founder and
chief executive of the software company
one disco has resigned after an internal
investigation into suspected fraud found
more than 115 million dollars in missing
bookings David Richards said he was sad
to be leaving one disco after 18
extremely enjoyable years Eric Miller
the Chief Financial Officer is also
stepping down with immediate effect well
Juan disco said that the investigation
had found that it sells for 2022 should
have been 9.7 million dollars rather
than 24 million dollars while bookings
should have been 11.4 million dollars
rather than 127 million dollars
the cinema operator cineworld said today
it's halted the sale process for its U.S
and UK and Ireland arms with immediate
effect the debt lading company said it's
planning to raise 2.26 billion dollars
as it seeks to emerge from chapter 11c
bankruptcy protection before the end of
June well cineworld whose Brands include
Regal Cinema City picture house and
Planet said the plan financial
restructuring would involve lenders
providing around 1.46 billion dollars in
new credit as well as buying 800 million
dollars worth of new shares and tell you
the Share Price is 37 percent lower
right now
and McDonald's is reportedly temporarily
closing its U.S offices this week as It
prepares to inform corporate employees
about Job cuts the Wall Street Journal
says the layoffs are part of a broader
company restructuring McDonald's which
employs more than 150 000 people around
the world in both corporate roles and in
its own owned restaurants said in
January that it planned to make
difficult decisions about changes to its
corporate Staffing Levels by April
our last Friday was a big day in
Gibraltar 14 years after work began on
it a tunnel for traffic to access the
frontier with Spain without having to
cross the runway at Gibraltar
International Airport well the new
tunnel for the first time since 1941
allows for an uninterrupted flow of
traffic from one side of the runway to
the other and it will significantly
improve traffic flow throughout
Gibraltar well joining me now is Mark's
walk suit Fork to apologize there Chief
Operating Officer of sunborn yacht
hotels in Gibraltar very good morning to
you sorry about uh struggle to pronounce
your surname there I mean this this
tunnel has taken an awful long time to
complete why the delays
well I don't know but there was a couple
of construction companies involved so
but good morning to you from Sunny
Travolta
the uh I mean the chart the tunnel has
actually taken longer to build than the
channel tunnel did between England and
France
very true yeah we're really excited yeah
we're hoping for more and more free flow
of uh traffic you know there's about 10
million
um arrivals every year uh so I think
that this is actually going to really
help open things up and um hopefully
bring more flights in as well
so what is this going to mean for your
business particularly
well the hotel occupancy is directly
related to uh the amount of uh people
arriving by air and um when I see this
as a great opportunity that there could
be more Airlines and more flights coming
into Gibraltar which would bring more
tourists and therefore improving the
occupancies of other hotels
how important is tourism to Gibraltars
economy
well it actually
constitutes around 130 million pounds of
Revenue per year
um sounds small I guess when you compare
it with the UK but um for this size of
economy
um it's quite large
um the total economy and the budget here
for Gibraltar is around 2.4 billion
um so there's a lot of other services
and things taking place but tourism as a
whole is super important we're only
approximately five hotels here
um in Gibraltar and um the sunborne
constitutes almost 200 of those and the
more the more tourists we can attract
and allow to come in smoothly and freely
the better off we will be now
gibraltarians voted in the brexit
referendum to remain in the EU by nearly
96 what is brexit meant for the border
crossings in particular I presume it's
added to some of the congestion not the
what we've been seeing in Dover over the
weekend
that's true a little bit more
um and it's uh I would call it maybe
more
um well it is stricter and there are
restrictions on the amount of days that
gibletarians can go into Spain and also
British citizens
um as well however
um I think as far as like with most
things you know once you get yourself
organized
um you know it's not really that much of
a problem anymore but presumably this
tunnel though is going to be a big
assistance in terms of helping flows
absolutely I've already driven it a
couple of times uh just to try to test
it and see how it went over the weekend
and now on a Monday
um it is uh samanasanta in Spain and
also you know the beginning of Easter
here
um so it's a little quieter but um I
have to say it um it's quite impressive
uh for a tunnel and um but it um it's
great it's really and I've been here in
Gibraltar for a little over six years
and
um I've been hearing about this tunnel
for you know practically every day since
and I'm just really thrilled that it's
finally here and open how many Spanish
Nationals roughly come into Gibraltar
every day
yeah that's a good point uh most of the
people that are traveling over which
constitutes around thirty thousand
um really by day
um
it's uh
probably about 90 percent are Spanish
and uh it's uh it's quite a number here
as you can see in this video the tunnels
yeah but uh presumably a lot of these
are your employees
that's correct yeah we employ around 180
people and again about 90 percent
um are uh from our Spanish Nationals
now that's not the only tunnel that's
currently under discussion in
gibraltario there's also talk of a
tunnel linking Spain and Morocco that
would go under the Gibraltar Strait what
would that mean for gibraltar's economy
oh I think that would uh well I'm I'm
unsure about how that would go but
that's the Gibraltar Strait is almost
900 meters deep
um I um I'm really really skeptical I
guess if you will about that but there
is
um the tunnel
um a pipeline sorry not a tunnel uh for
oil and um electricity that comes from
uh Algeria to Spain so I guess it can
happen
um
that would change things quite a bit
because there is a lot of trade between
Morocco and Gibraltar uh we we
personally I mean uh you know here at
the hotel we do get a lot of supplies
that are coming from uh Morocco and so I
think that that would immensely uh
change things uh to connect Africa uh to
the Iberian Peninsula
I'm Mark your business right now what
what are occupancy levels like
well we're fluctuating and it's a kind
of a let's say a pre-pandemic and normal
winter
um right now you know we're hovering
anywhere between 70 to 80 percent
occupancy
um we grow up a little bit more uh
during the summer
and have longer stays our normal stay
now is roughly around two to three
nights
um but um in the summertime that extends
to around five to seven nights
um we we see around a hundred thousand
people a year
um here at the hotel and staying in the
hotel and
um you know the thing is though with the
addition of more flights
um we could see that grow right now
there's approximately 40 flights per
week during the winter time there's
around 18 to 20. so if we could see that
uh increasing any amount
um that would definitely affect their
business
very good Mark we have to leave it there
good to see you this morning thanks for
joining me thank you very much I
appreciate it and welcome to Gibraltar
thank you Mark Mark's Mark there
now most big management consultancies
the likes of Mackenzie Bain Boston
Consulting and the Consulting arm of big
four accountants such as Deloitte and
PWC are owned by their Partners it's
much rarer to see them listed on the
stock market and owned by shareholders
that's the model though for Elixir
International which listed on AIM in
June 2020 during the middle of the first
covid lockdown and which stars itself
the Challenger consultancy will today
the company whose clients include HSBC
Tesla and Mars reporter the full year
pre-tax profit for 2022 a 15.7 million
pounds that was up 29 on 2021 well the
founder and chief executive is Stephen
Newton and he joins me now Stephen
welcome to you I mean traditionally you
specialized in financial services retail
and digital you branched out into other
disciplines there where is growth
strongest right now well there's three
ways you can good morning firstly and
good morning to our viewers there's
three ways you can look at growth and we
look at it in a geography lens we also
look at an industry lens and we also
look at it in a capability lens and
geography right now our biggest growth
Market is the US it's by Far and Away
the biggest Consulting Market out there
and we sing very accelerated growth up
north of 50 in the US market and then if
you look at it by industry we've as you
mentioned we were initially strong in in
financial services we're branching out
into telco's consumer goods
Pharmaceuticals retail Etc that's
another another view on on the on the
perspective and then the the third one
is capability so we we focusing on
digital Innovation transformation cost
reduction which is very interesting in a
downward trending Market when in a
headwind market so to speak so yeah
we've seen growth from all of those
areas that's very interesting so I mean
it sounds from what you're saying though
it's it's about managing specific
challenges like costs like the needs for
digital transformation less than going
for growth almost well it's interesting
I mean clearly the market is a bit tough
in the last year I mean we're very
pleased with our results having grown uh
30 uh over the year and 18 underlying
growth so that was uh really really
encouraging for us but all our clients
were facing difficult challenges of
course but what we're finding is that I
think it's what it's meaning is people
are being a bit more focused you know so
where clients are seeing a lot of our
clients are focusing on digital because
they're realizing that's a big future
they need to be in that space of course
now there's a bit more emphasis on cost
reduction Supply Chain management and
all of that kind of good thing as well
so it's it's a question of being more
precise now I think now you're obviously
not paying McKinsey style salaries and
your industry is notorious for people
job hopping is Staff retention an issue
for you well interestingly we've got a
very interesting model you mentioned it
at the start that we're listed company
and it's a very specific model you
mentioned that we're a Challenger we're
trying to challenge the industry in
terms of its remuneration model and
they're not many listed companies in the
top ten there's only three and the
Market's bifurcated a little bit it's
almost 50 of the top ten and and then
the other 50 is at hundreds of thousands
of small boutique firms like ours but
we're using the equity model to
incentivize both our partners and our
staff and we think that brings a much
longer term perspective for
um for up for our people so they
actually have to stick around and earn
the value so our partners are probably
70 motivated in equity which is very
different to the cash model of the big
firms who do you hire people from uh
well our favorite is to grow people
internally right
um one of our other strategies is also
to acquire Boutique firms I mentioned
entrepreneurialism the thing about
um
the boutique firms these firms exist
because they've probably got founder
members founder Partners who are very
entrepreneurial themselves and so we'd
like to bring in those Founders into our
entire businesses through an acquisition
strategy and that complements our
existing team are all very
entrepreneurial people too so we
obviously take from the big firms but
that's the more difficult proposition
because we find that they're not um
they're not as entrepreneurial and we
want a bit more of an entrepreneurial
Edge to to our people yeah now you
mentioned that uh more than 40 of your
revenues come from the US now you've
done a big acquisition there recently is
there still more in the tank you're
looking for more Acquisitions oh yeah
constantly you know we're we've you know
I mentioned there's hundreds of
thousands of Boutique firms out there
we've looked at over four thousand and
um continuously looking at at good firms
and when we see good opportunities like
the acquisition of iLab party in the US
um where it's fitting a specific
geography opportunity for us which is
the us but also data and analytics which
is key to decision making now in
boardrooms we obviously wanted to
complement our skills with that so
always looking for things that
complement the the business model we're
trying to adopt now as you say you're in
a lot of different countries a lot of
different industry uh sectors where is
optimism most positive right now
um I'd say tell me it is somewhere yeah
no look I mean it is difficult but um I
think the Consulting industry itself has
seen 15 years of growth
um and while it is slowing a little bit
it's still growing so I think the
Consulting industry is growing it's
quite resilient to recessions actually
Consulting because you could you're
either focusing on Revenue in good times
or cost reduction efficiency in in sort
of more difficult times
um I think that's that's probably uh the
industry that's probably the most
positive in my view right now yeah but I
mean obviously digital transformation is
driving an awful lot of business of
course which are the sectors that are
dragging their feet on on digital
transformation and not perhaps doing as
much as they ought to well it's very
difficult to say sector wise but I'd say
you know we tend to work with those
clients who are challenging and moving
into the digital world so you know our
clients are pretty bold and they're out
there trying to embrace the change that
they need to embrace
um obviously there's always la our Gods
I wouldn't say there's a specific
industry that I would I would point out
point to but you know it can be within
the industry there's certain clients
that perhaps have a different model or
more streets High Street model or a more
Digital model so it does depend on the
industry and it does depend on on the
sector I guess a little bit I mean we're
obviously very inflation conscious right
now and you mentioned that clients are
looking to cut costs where they can yeah
sometimes that might even involve
cutting consultancy fees what's
happening to you on the fee front well
I'm a great believer in if you deliver
value you get paid daily you know so I
think a profit this is part of the
reason we wanted to be public too is if
you show good profits you're showing
your clients good value and uh this is a
this is a um a truism if you like so
um you always get pressure if you're
doing poor surface if you if you're
making a difference and adding value
then the pressure's not so much so yeah
I don't feel that there's any particular
change in the market I think it's just
the same kind of pressure clients are
demanding and they should be
um and we've got to deliver to them and
then they power pair of fees all right
Stephen got to leave it there busy day
for your results they do appreciate you
spending the time to chat to us thank
you thank you
a little bit of breaking news to bring
you you'll be aware overnight there was
an explosion in Saint Petersburg which
killed a well-known pro-war Russian
blogger or Russia's National
anti-terrorism Committee has just issued
a statement in which it says it has been
established that the terrorist attack
against the military blogger vladlen
tatasky in Saint Petersburg yesterday
was planned by the Ukrainian special
services more on that throughout the
morning here on Sky News of course and
still to come here on E King live we'll
have a look at how Global markets are
doing this Monday morning the start of
course of the second quarter don't go
away
[Music]
thank you
this is the story of the night are you
feeling well there's this illusion of
power it's like an across to us live
okay thank you so much Brad Pitt is now
a prolific producer behind the scene I
want to beat that guy okay I'll talk to
you yeah okay
I've had a great time here I love
England and would like to move here
thank you thank you bye
I'm Greg mylam and I'm Sky's Chief north
of England correspondent
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
thank you
well the oil price is obviously at the
center of attention this morning
following the production cuts and that's
Yesterday by the OPEC plus grouping
barrel of Brent crude we mentioned it at
the top of the program is trading at
84.44 there you go it's currently 84.21
cents a barrel still up nearly five and
a half percent on the session well on
the equity markets it was largely a
positive session overnight in the Asia
Pacific region Sydney finished up
two-thirds of one percent the knicker
and Tokyo was off up half of one percent
Shanghai got the yellow leader vest that
was up three quarters of one percent
Hong Kong more or less unchanged when
buy was very slightly lower well in
Europe stocks have made a healthy start
to the second quarter the uh catcaront
in Paris currently ahead buyer just
under half of one percent the movie
Milan is up by half of one percent
that's in Frankfurt up a tenth of one
percent right now and the Ibex in Madrid
were more or less unchanged they're here
in London the ftse 100 is also in
positive territory right now up to
thirds of one percent that's a three
week I led by the oil Majors as you
might expect BP and shell alone there
you go the footsies 52 points to the
good there well 39 points of that alone
has come from BP and shells some of the
banking stocks are ahead this morning as
well well outside the ftse 100 again
it's all about the oil stocks this
morning Harbor energy that's the biggest
independent producer in the North Sea
and uh tullo oil though both up by
around six percent a piece there you go
well tullo's up five percent now hunting
that's another interesting well that's
an oil services provider it shares up
some five and three quarter percent
right now among the fallers will the
cyber security group NCC you'll recall
we mentioned them last week they had an
absolute Lulu of a profits warning the
shares are off another four percent this
morning elsewhere always there is off
some three percent right now it's
published some passenger numbers this
morning on the foreign exchange markets
well all that uh talk about OPEC
production Cuts uh spot the dollar into
a bit of Life there but as you can see
uh it's uh given some of those bat
knives Sterling actually more or less
unchanged right now against both the
dollar and the Euro likewise The single
currency more or less unchanged against
the dollar well I'm joined Now by Neil
Wilson he's Chief Market Analyst at
fenelto Neil good to see you this
morning
um we can't avoid talking about the oil
price but I guess the bigger question
people will have is what will this mean
for the broader inflation picture yes I
mean clearly it's not a not great for
inflation if oil prices are are higher
we saw a lot of inflation over the last
couple of years has been driven by
energy
um you know you are starting to see that
that fall with the latest data has
suggested that you know the the base
effects from from from energy is
starting to contribute to to lower
inflation
um I think that the worry would be that
you know you just get this flare up
again in in in that sort of energy
component of the inflation data it just
makes the overall more sticky
um I think on you know on the sort of
broader broader sort of look at it um
you know the the services inflation that
we're seeing right now is incredibly
sticky it's not going away if you if you
combine that with with energy inflation
two then you're gonna you're gonna get a
tougher environment for the central
banks and and you know probably see
probably see some more tightening have
to take to take place which is why I
presume all the banking stocks are in
pretty fine fatal this morning well so
that's certainly the case I think as
well you know you've you have seen a bit
of Cam being restored with uh regards to
the banking crisis if you if you can
call it a crisis I think
um it certainly was a was a very
um big impact on certain Banks we've
seen that but but on the whole it looks
like the Market's kind of coming around
to the idea that you know there might be
problems underlying here there might be
something happening there might be a
credit you know credit tightening credit
crunch down the line but we're not going
to see sort of 2008 style uh implosion
what are your Reflections on the first
quarter I mean it actually turned out to
be a lot better than people are
expecting if you look at some of the
Continental European stock indices I
mean the Dax in Germany and the cacaront
in France were up by sort of 11 12 not
bad going yeah there are some great
great performances yeah I think you look
at it partly on the sort of the amount
of sailing that was done in 2022 so you
saw a bit of a a bit of a snapback and
the footsie had a much more sort of
circumspect uh quarter because it had
actually done really quite well in 2022.
I think on the whole you call that a
kind of formal trade I think um we saw
it throughout 22 uh wherever the the
market was buying into this idea that
the Fed was going to Pivot pause
whatever you call it start you know
looking to stop hiking rates and that's
kind of what we've been seeing this this
quarter too and I think uh you've seen a
big big
um bid for for tech stocks in particular
NASDAQ up about 17 for the quarter
um I think there's an element of uh
chasing safety
um in that and it sort of sounds strange
to talk about tech as a safe place but
in a in a world of great uncertainty
High inflation and
um you know the FED may be looking to
actually pause rate hikes
um then then Tech actually maybe has has
some appeal and that that's what we've
been looking at this over the first
quarter yeah I'm quite surprised though
looking at the markets today how
sanguine people are being you know OPEC
have just cut production bad for bad for
uh inflation as you say potentially
pointing to more interest rates and yet
more or less everywhere is up again this
morning I think I I think there's
there's an element of uncertainty about
what how much this cut will actually
feed into real terms cut so you know
what what amount of it is actually
already out of the market
um what sort of demand kind of
Destruction we might be looking at
um you know there's a sense that Opex
trying to get ahead of the story here
trying to it's making a sort of
strategic cut here looking at away
looking at
um you know the the sort of instability
of all prices as being a problem as well
as as well as the absolute level of the
oil price it's actually about making
sure that the stability it doesn't want
to see it go from 140 to 35 and back
again it wants it to keep it around 80.
so I think you know you're not
necessarily going to see a massive
amount of oil coming off the market and
therefore you're not going to see a
massive spike in oil prices well I
thought was interesting overnight was
the way the dollar traded because you
normally expect the dollar and the oil
price to go in opposite directions but
they actually Rose in tandem yeah I
think maybe a bit of um sort of chasing
quality chasing safety with the dollar
to catching some bid it had it had come
off a bit uh in in the last couple of
weeks we've seen Sterling right rise
quite quite well over the last couple of
over the last couple of weeks I think
maybe just a bit of a a kind of pairing
back of those of those moves um and also
maybe a bit of flight to safety because
there's an element that says that if
Vulpix doing this it's starting to panic
it's starting to maybe worry it's
starting to worry about what might
happen in a few in a few months time if
there is a um if this credit tightening
that we're seeing from the banks uh
because of the the problems that they're
having actually does lead to to a credit
Crunch and what that would mean for the
economy in the meantime what are you
hearing from investors and clients right
now about the situation in Ukraine I
mean it's kind of dropped a bit down the
sort of running orders in in The
Newsroom somewhat it has it has I think
from Financial Market point of view
we've seen it unwind most of the the
sort of the big moves that we saw last
year this time last year in particular
in the commodity spaces have have to a
large extent Unwound and and there's not
the same sort of feeling of uh of the
emergency sort of sense of if you like
the sort of
um doom doom and gloom is there's a
sense that it's rolling on in the
background it's very sad in a way that
it's no it's not seen as important but
it's once it's I you know what all these
things are the same once they're priced
in if you like to the market the market
accepts that's the norm
um then then it's just happening in the
background all the time and that's
that's the nature of the markets yeah
Neil good to see you this morning thank
you
still to come here on Ian King live as
Broadband bills rise I'll be speaking to
one company that says it won't be going
for mid-contract Price hikes don't go
away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back now the start of this month
saw price increases for the millions of
households or phone or Broadband
contracts are linked to the rate of
inflation it's an established practice
but given the current High rate of
inflation has attracted much more
attention than usual this year and it's
prompted the industry regulator ofcom to
review whether contracts contain
sufficient Clarity for customers will
join him in as Richard Tang he's founder
and chief executive of Zen internet
which does not engage in so-called
mid-contract price hikes Richard morning
to you why don't you go in for this well
the main reason is for to give customer
certainty so if if a customer stands up
with a broadband service you contract
them for a year or 18 months then isn't
it right that they have certainty during
that contract period about what they're
going to pay certainly in the B2B world
that is the case but for some reason in
the consumer World it isn't and it
hasn't been for a long time and I mean
you do charge slightly more than some of
your competitors to balance that out yes
we do and again I think we do that
because of certainty we do that because
of the quality of service I mean Zen is
the UK's only which recommended provider
and and
they we think that that's better than
trying to capture lots of market share
with a very very attractive offer but
then almost trick the customer that well
okay but part way through your contract
you're going to get a price hike maybe
at the end of the contract you're going
to get another price hike and it's that
uncertainty I think that we we don't
like well BT which is the market leader
I mean that they do engage in this their
case for the defense is that they're
actually doing what ofcorm has told the
industry to do by uh you know it's
actually more clear if they know that
they're going to raise prices once a
year it's better than some of these
unplanned and unannounced price hikes
that used to get in the past
well I think the idea that ofcom has
told any of the big players to height
their prices mid-contract is twisting
the truth a bit
um what ofcom has said to open reach is
that open reach is allowed to do certain
things and then to raise certain prices
but what the Broadband providers do for
their consumers is absolutely in their
email and the fact that Zen doesn't hike
prices and the other other the big
players do
shows that you know this isn't an
off-com mandate this is the choice of
the supplier
um and it's the choice that we've chosen
not to take I mean we should point out
that not everyone does it I'm in virgin
media and Sky I think don't uh put these
midterm price hikes into their contracts
either do their own summer products it's
quite complex playing field this isn't
it it is some players put it in the
small print they say your price will be
height on the 1st of April for example
some of them don't but then hike the
prices anyway and say okay we put your
price up you can leave for free
but if you stay you've got a a prayer
tag on the whole the biggest the bigger
Broadband providers do tend to hike
prices mid contract
at least now they tell customers in the
small print what they've done in Years
Gone by is they'll lock customers into a
contract and then unilaterally they'll
hike prices typically just before
Christmas when people are least likely
to switch and then say look you can get
out for free
um but of course you don't want to be
switching your Broadband before
Christmas and of course they just cash
in then on another pay in a month or two
pounds a month yeah now it's very
fortuitous that we've got you here in
the studio because while we've been on
air offcom have actually uh hit the
entire industry with an enforcement uh
ruling this is over something called one
touch switch Broadband what does that
involve for the uninitiated so off comes
intentions are are really good they want
to make it as easy as possible for
consumers to switch their Broadband
supplier just like with with electricity
or gas and but they put in a a timeline
that the whole industry was telling them
it was not achievable and so the whole
industry was lobbying to say look we'll
do our best and certainly at Zen we've
got all the software ready but the
software that all us Broadband players
need to interface to
um was was not come in so it's like how
can we how can we put this new system in
place when the system we're interfacing
to doesn't even exist yet and so ofcom
they were very firm they said no we're
holding to the day and I think they you
know they almost expected that the
industry as a whole would uh would fail
to meet the day I think what Zen will do
and what other Broadband providers will
do you know we'll work as fast as we can
to get everything in place but we need
all the pieces to actually plug into but
essentially when this comes in it means
that if I want to switch my Broadband
accounts uh I just ring up the new
supplier and it's all taken care of from
that end it's it's much more
straightforward yeah and already
operates like that and that it's it's
it's gaining provider LED switching and
but this one such switching process
makes it even a step easy it really as
simple as changing your power supplier
for example you just say that I want to
switch bang that's done so a good idea
but
um an over ambitious time scale from
ofcoming my view so given that you've
just said that when would a more
realistic timetable be for this to be
implemented uh difficult so I'd need to
speak to our software team and I'd need
to speak to offcome on that at some
point later this year I would I would
expect yeah and presumably when it
happens this is going to be pretty good
news for your business as a challenger
brand yeah definitely I think anything
that makes it easier for customers to
switch is good news for Zen
um for us we we tend not to light a lot
customers into a contract and think you
know they're staying because they're
locked into a contract actually the
majority of our customer base are out of
contract so they stay with us because
they like the service they could go with
a month's notice but they're staying
because they like the service and we
we've done that for 28 years now and
very good okay with that well Before I
Let You Go I mean the last time we we
spoke you were talking about a big
recruitment drive up in Rochdale where
you're based how's that been going uh
yeah we're at 560 people now and going
really well so we're doing well growing
every year
good to hear Richard lovely to see you
again thanks for joining me this morning
thank you very much
still to come here Ronnie and King live
the AI based assistant for online
meetings that can take notes translate
and provide analysis all in real time
don't go away
[Music]
thank you
this is the story of the night are you
feeling well there's this illusion of
power it's like an across to us live
okay thank you so much Brad Pitt is now
a prolific producer behind the scene I
want to be that guy okay I'll talk to
you
yeah okay
I've had a great time here I love
England and would like to move here
thank you thank you bye
[Music]
I'm Greg Milam and I'm Sky's Chief north
of England correspondent
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Sky News Financial reports sponsored by
interactive investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back we're gonna have a look at
this morning's business Pages now we
don't have the regular graphic to show
you this morning but I'm joined by our
sister channel CNBC The Anchor Juliana
Julia good to see you this is the front
page of the ft
no surprises they're leading with with
OPEC I guess what would you take on this
story big story over the weekend and big
surprise surprise so no wonder they are
leading with the story
um essentially OPEC plus came out over
the weekend led by Saudi Arabia and
announced a production cut so a cut to
oil supplies coming onto the market over
the next month starting next months and
running into the end of the year and
this is a big deal because Saudi wants a
higher oil price and this is essentially
a signal that the US has really lost its
influence in the region this could have
a detrimental impact on the U.S economy
by a higher energy prices the impact
that could have on inflation and just
more generally what this says about the
influence of the Biden Administration in
that part of the world in terms of what
it means for the price of oil Goldman
Sachs came out today and so we could see
the oil price Brent oil price rise to 95
a barrel by the end of the year I spoke
to Andy critchlow from s p Global Platz
earlier today
um he agreed we could see oil prices
Edge higher closer to 100 a barrel is
what Saudi and some of the other OPEC
patients want and it really marks a
dramatic shift in these geopolitical
allegiances it really does I mean you
put your finger on a really crucial
point though I mean Saudi Arabia has
traditionally been a very reliable Ally
for America in the region is that in
danger of breaking down permanently do
you think well at the moment it is very
clear that Saudi is getting Cozier with
Asian Nations who've been buying cheaper
oil over the last several months from
Russia and from Middle Eastern Nations
and again drawing on what s p Global
pots have said this morning you can't
really look at this situation in
isolation the these core oil producers
are getting closer to China they're
getting closer to Russia they want to
operate in what s p calls a multi a
polar World they don't want to be
completely reliant on the U.S so it is
really hard to see how the U.S regains
its leverage in the region right now
yeah it's a fascinating story of this
move on this is the uh Daily Telegraph
front page this is the bottom half of it
so 3 000 city jobs in Jeopardy as UBS
prepares credit Swiss layoffs I mean
this is basically implying that jobs are
going to go UBS as well as Credit Suisse
well it's super interesting because
initially when the UBS Credit Suisse
deal was announced people thought that
Credit Suisse jobs were the ones at risk
now it looks as though with Sergio
Armani returning to the Helm of UBS and
he's known as a powerful and sometimes
ruthless leader we could be looking at
jobs at risk across the two entities so
here's what we know Swiss media
reporting that we could see the
workforce cut by 20 to 30 percent not a
huge amount of detail into which job
specifically are at risk but the reports
suggest that more than ten thousand jobs
are at risk in Switzerland alone we may
see some jobs cut in the U.S as well and
that's because UBS coming on board UBS
wants to scrap a deal that was in the
works to sell credit species Investment
Bank to Michael Klein the Wall Street
deal maker if that deal goes away then
suddenly you're looking at overlap
between the investment banking
businesses as well as the other business
units yeah horrific so I mean the state
prosecutors also looking at this in
Switzerland as well which I just find
bizarre given that this was instigated
by the Swiss government it's such a good
point and I mean even looking at the
these job Cuts it's so important to bear
in mind that this deal didn't come about
organically UBS didn't raise its hand
and say I want to merge I want to
acquire Credit Suisse depending on which
language you want to take this deal was
orchestrated by the Swiss government the
Swiss National Bank and the market
regulator a lot of open questions still
and we could get a few more answers this
week we've got coverage in Zurich and in
broader switzerlands week we've got
Credit Suisse and UBS both looking to
give updates to the market all right
gotta leave it there Juliana great to
see you this morning thanks for joining
me
now since the lockdowns we've all got
used to having virtual meetings some of
which can drag on a bit and one reason
they can drag on a bit is is hard to
take notes while engaging with
participants well it was with that in
mind that a group of Polish
entrepreneurs sought to develop an AI
based assistant for online meetings that
can take notes translate and provide
analysis all in real time the company is
called smarty meat and it's just
completed precede fundraising with
Amazon web services portfolio and the
Venture Capital firm LT Capital
participating or joining me now is none
of their crochet Who's chief executive
of smarty meat slavonia welcome to you
you've chosen to launch first of all in
the UK why is that
uh hello thank you for having me
why UK
we are integrated with the HubSpot CRM
system and HubSpot is well established
player in the sales software market and
has a significant present in UK
there is a steady increase in adoption
among small and medium-sized Enterprises
which are our ideal customers
what's the what's the route to Market
are you selling directly to to customers
or do you have third party distribution
so our platform is reserved for B2B for
Paul small and medium-sized Enterprises
and
about our product we are online meeting
platform using AI for smooth enjoyable
meetings boosting productivity and a
comfort for sales and I.T professionals
what sets smart emit apart from the
other Solutions is the comprehensive
support provided by our virtual
assistant called well which supports you
before during and after virtual meetings
who gives you best eye body on the
meeting and he is not going to replace
you before a meeting take place Bo helps
you to pick the right agenda or meeting
and prepare you for call by displaying
Recaps of the past conversation and
activities Bob gives you an information
about attendees and the companies they
work for ensuring you are well prepared
for the meeting
during meetings Bob provides a real-time
transcription and translation allowing
you to focus on discussion you can track
a Time on the timeline Mark and
important moments and review them later
if attendees has a tricky technical
question uh
Balkan access the company knowledge base
to give you an answer
finally after the meeting our assistant
bow can has you covered with
well-organized meeting notes that align
with the agenda sections you can easily
edit and share those nodes with your
team via email or transfer them to your
own CRM system smart emit streamlines
the process to ensure everyone stays in
a loop and we are use the pay as you go
business model
so you only pay for actual use of both
assistant without that monthly
subscription on average you will pay
just one British pound for half an hour
meeting
and how big is the addressable Market in
your opinion
well the market is is very large we are
aiming the companies who are using the
CRM system so this is this is billions
of dollars
now you're using uh open uh Source AI
like chat GPT and Whisperer in this
service why is that
well every meeting is different and
acquire a previous agenda and tools with
the right agenda you'll stay on track
and you will not lose your time and be
more prepared we understand that that's
why we offer dozens of predefined
agendas and to choose from and you can
you own agenda is visible visible all
the time on the meeting after the
meeting our notes are more structured
and more precise since we understand
different meeting types
and we can create a domain specific
recap of each section and in this case
chart GPT and Whisper camps in handy
very good Slovenia it's very good to
speak to you this morning we're going to
leave it there I'm afraid thanks for
joining me
thank you very much
have a great day
that's it from me I'm back at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning hope very much to see
you then in the meantime do stay tuned
after this short break it's Kimberly
Leonard thanks for joining me today
foreign
[Music]
thank you